there is an emerging conflict tonight
between the people who want to keep this
country safe
and the engineers who have developed the
machines to do that national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin tells us
some of them no longer want to
participate the US military is
developing a fleet of drones known as
gremlins to swarm the battlefield it's
working on robotic tanks submarine
drones and ships that can deploy for
months without any humans on board now
after teaming up with Silicon Valley
it's facing a rebellion from high-tech
civilian engineers who don't want their
expertise used to develop artificial
intelligence that could be used to kill
the technology is going to take us right
up to the point where it will be
possible to take humans out of the kill
chain a dozen Google employees quit this
week after more than three thousand
signed a petition demanding the high
tech giant not partner with the Pentagon
on project maven a DoD program allowing
computers to replace humans to wade
through hours of drone video quote we
believe that Google should not be in the
business of war therefore we ask that
project maven be cancelled and that
Google draft publicized and enforce a
clear policy stating that neither Google
nor its contractors will ever build
warfare technology the Pentagon is
collecting so much data off of Thrones
they can't possibly put enough people on
these video feeds to actually watch them
all Paul Sciarra author of army of none
worked at the Pentagon from 2008 to 2013
he explains the culture gap between
Silicon Valley and the Defense
Department what happens when a Predator
drone has as much autonomy as a
self-driving car and how much autonomy
are we willing to cede to machines when
we're talking about life and death
decisions the Pentagon says human beings
will still select the targets but with
an artificial intelligence arms race
already underway the US military fears
being left behind
China has ordered its technology giants
to help it advance on the battlefield
rush
developing fleets of armed robots and
has deployed robotic tanks to Syria
Google's Eric Schmidt sits on the
Pentagon's defense innovation board and
google says project maven is for quote
non offensive purposes but the company
may still need to convince their
engineers Brett Jennifer Griffin at the
Pentagon Jennifer thank you